[Music]
when we look out at the heavens we can
see billions of galaxies and trillions
of stars they generally look evenly
spread out but in 2015
scientists spots something strange but
every now and then we find something we
can't explain there is a giant area
that's colder and emptier than it
possibly could be there's not very much
matter in there there's not that many
galaxies there's not much energy in
there and we call these voids and some
of them are quite large they're called
super voids one of these super voids is
1.8 billion light years across
making it the largest individual
structure ever identified by humanity
this void has 20% less matter 10,000
less galaxies than would be expected
that equates to about a thousand
trillion stars all missing
we are not completely sure how the
cosmic boy formed we know the layout of
the galaxies was determined at the very
start of the universe so it makes sense
to take a look at the Big Bang
or more specifically a baby picture of
the infant universe when it was just
380,000 years old
it's a snapshot of the Cosmic Microwave
Background the pattern of heat left over
from the Big Bang when you look at maps
of the microwave background we see
different colors red and blue those
aren't real colors they're artificial
colors that we put down to indicate
where the temperature is a little hotter
than the average and a little colder
than the average not by much
merely one part in 10,000 the regions
that appear tiny bit warmer had slightly
more material
[Applause]
they would go on to form galaxies and
all of the structures we observe in the
universe today the colder regions had
less matter so didn't form complex
structures it's thought that some of
these less dense areas ended up forming
the super voids
you